you know as a comedian you there you
have hecklers right in in live shows
there's
there you know you get hecklers and
at first when i was young i would be so
hurt
or you know and um you realize
what the subtext of all these heckles
are which is
i exist right you know and that's like
times a thousand on the internet you
know
people just writing things to try to
prove they exist and and they're shocked
if you see it
you know that's true i i have poked my
head in
um and someone has said something really
mean about me
and that i've responded have been like
hey sorry you felt that way
like you know like uh like you know
i'll like i'll keep at it like smiley
face or something like that and then it
completely defuses their reaction if you
can change that energy
to you know which is what you did you
respond and you go oh sorry you feel
that way you know and then that person
felt
seen it's science you know energy it
can't be what is it
uh created nor destroyed but it can
change
it can convert from negative you know
someone flips you off on the street it's
like
you you take it on and you it's catchy
you know
so if you can just really consciously i
mean what am i marianne williamson
i mean i love her i'm just kidding but i
i i sometimes i hear myself
talk and i go aren't you a comic
[Music]
welcome back to yang speaks this is your
co-host zach grauman
i hope everyone's having a great week
excited to talk to you all
i hope we're staying sane and safe only
losing our mind mildly
in covid i know i'm only slightly losing
my mind so i hope you guys are okay a
couple things we have
news today before we get in an episode
very very exciting um i wanna do three
things before we dive into the episode
we've got
uh updates for you on yang's covid
situation
i've got some big news for the future of
this podcast and then we've got sarah
silverman
on the podcast which is very exciting
it's a great episode today and going
forward
so let's start with some updates on
andrew andrew is feeling better
um but he does have the coco he does
have kovid um
so he's we've been joking as we talk a
lot and he was like um
he's like i'm frustrated because i'm two
percent better every day but two percent
is not enough to
feel good about a speedy recovery so
he's getting there it's slow
um it's funny because he's so he's so go
go go and so in the morning he's like
calling me he's like he's all excited
about here's what i'm gonna do today
we're great i'm gonna be back and by
like three o'clock he's like wheezing a
bit
um so it's frustrating to see him like
that be honest with you because he's
usually so
frankly kind of invincible um and so
it's like watching your hero
uh recover and that's hard um and i feel
for him and his family but um he is
getting better and that's exciting we're
gonna try and get him out in person
and fully recovered is um by the end of
this weekend hopefully um like the
timing has been
um gotten there so he's he's on his way
very very soon to recovery and should be
back at full strength in this podcast
hopefully
in a week but just wanted to let you
guys know thank you for many of you
thousands of you who sent thoughts and
prayers and get well cards um i try to
like as many as i could on twitter but
um
thank you thank you um and on instagram
um
so that's our andrew yang kovid update
um
now i want to transition to some news
which is very exciting so
a couple weeks ago given some political
activity uh in the
uh andrew yang atmosphere universe if
you will
um we decided to go to just one episode
a week
on this podcast and a lot of you were
still craving more content
and i wanted to change that a bit so
we're going to try something new so
we've been doing just mondays
so i have an announcement this is our
news today we're going to go back to
mondays and thursdays
for the next 12 weeks we are going to
start um
a new limited series starting this
thursday so new limited series
this thursday and it's called the future
of and it's going to be hosted by yours
truly and we're going to dive in
to the topics that all of you have been
clamoring for
um for weeks and months since we've
basically a year since we started this
thing
the goal will be long-form conversations
on
the topics that are going to impact our
future the most and to not only do a
deep dive on like what they are
but also how they impact our humanity
how they impact our policy very much in
the andre yang vein
which is not just that automation's
happening but because of automation we
need to rewrite the rules of our economy
and we needed to help people like how
does this hit our humanity so
um it's not always going to be famous
people um it's going but it's going to
be people
who have a depth of knowledge that we
can learn from and i want to learn um
and i hope you guys will go with me on
this journey to kind of talk about our
future and understand it better so i've
got
a whole bunch of awesome guests lined up
basically through the yang
and the yang gang network uh that are
really exciting so we're gonna do
episodes on the future of
buying like what is going on in
e-commerce and how is amazon and
facebook changing the way we market and
buy and sell goods we want to do an
episode with a number of energy experts
on the future of energy like
how when we say the planet is melting
what
does that mean and what do we need to do
um to prevent that over the next
10 20 30 years um how do we get there i
want to do an episode on the future of
money and break down cryptocurrency and
things like that
future philanthropy i think will be fun
like what is how's the non-profit space
going to help solve some of these social
ills can they what does that look like
the future of sports i want to dive into
esports i think this is one of the most
un unknown topics in the entire world
and it is massive more people
watched um a certain video game
championship than they watched the
college football playoffs like and no
one's talking about it i want to dive in
guys
on the issues that are going to impact
our future
and i hope you all will join me um i'm
going to co-host it with
carly riley um as much as she can
because i think she makes all of us
smarter um and is better at this than
most of us so i think she'll be joining
with those who have
um double affinity for her on this
podcast as well we'll have recurring
guests and things like that
it's gonna be awesome now here's the
deal we're gonna give this shot
12 weeks give it a listen you don't like
it just tune in on mondays
but if you do like it and hopefully i'm
gonna believe i'm gonna put a lot as
much effort as we can to make this worth
your time i think we're all to learn
something and we're going to get what we
all crave which is discussing the things
the policy effects the humanity effects
that all impact our future so give it a
shot
starts this thursday the future of you
all
are going to like it i believe and we'd
love your feedback let's make it better
as we go this is iterative so comment be
nice humanity first geez don't don't
kill me come on now
but it's going to be fun so the future
of here's thursday
y'all are going to love it i'm going to
love it it's very exciting i've already
recorded a couple episodes we're feeling
pretty good now with that news
it's time to introduce our guest speaker
the one and only sarah silverman
sarah is i think she's in the news for a
whole bunch of things all the time it's
kind of kind of a wild card in that way
so and the episode is kind of that way
too where they talk about
everything from kovid to having fame
to dealing with the haters online and in
person and they also talk about politics
and positions and how we can start
getting along it's a fascinating episode
from a fascinating human being i love
when these
just remarkable like whether you like
love her comedy or not she's definitely
an interesting
unique human on the planet and getting
people like that on yang speaks is
always interesting and hearing yang's
perspective and conversation
with them is is always great so you've
got sarah silverman today we've got the
future of starting thursday
i'm excited for this new journey so tune
in now sarah silverman
i want to talk to you all about your
most valuable asset
and that is time we always are running
out of it
we never can have enough of it so that's
why we have partnered with stamps.com
because what they do better than most
things particularly when you're mailing
stuff is save
you time so stamps.com brings the
service of the us postal service and ups
right to your computer so you can get
your stamps print them online
and save a trip to the post office
because that is
by definition a hassle so save your time
you can use this 24 7 and get your
stamps at stamps.com from anywhere in
the world
so here's what i want you to do stop
wasting time go in the post office and
go to stamps.com
instead there's no risk and with our
promo code yang you get a special offer
that includes a four-week trial
plus free postage and a digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts so go
to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page type in yang that's
stamps.com promo code yang
stamps.com never go to the post office
again
i am so thrilled to welcome to yang
speak someone i have admired for years
someone who has done the impossible
which is
make it as like a sane wise human being
in show business sarah silverman welcome
hello what's up andrew
not a whole lot i'm trapped in my kid's
room because i'm in the
last days of a covet quarantine i don't
know if you you saw that uh
um i i tested positive a little while
ago but i'm on the mend i don't know if
you can tell like you know i
i feel like a cloud is lifting from my
brain
yeah yeah i can see now yeah
you look mildly sickly still
and yet mildly healthy too
yeah mildly healthy that's more the
glass half full
how about you are you in uh california
right now are you here in new york
i'm in california i had that sense how
is it out there
i'm uh it seems great because i'm
i don't go anywhere but i'm terrified i
just you know kind of don't want to do
anything um until i can get a vaccine
and that won't be for a long time so
i don't i mean i don't know when do you
think like uh
people like you know a regular uh person
can get a vaccine that's not over 65.
non-high-risk people i'm told by
america's
uncle dr fauci
[Laughter]
apparently april uh the vaccines are
going to be going out in full force and
normal humans
uh might be able to expect them yeah you
know that that's what the band said
oh that's so awesome
so sarah you and i have something in
common that you would probably not know
um and it's that we spent our formative
years in new hampshire because i went uh
i went to high school there
where'd you go oh well i went to exeter
or something
yeah yeah
yeah you know i always wanted i always
dream we play
like our sports team would play not
exeter but we'd play like saint paul's
yeah you know usually and i remember
seeing their campus and just being like
oh my i would love this but i couldn't
go because
i was a chronic bedwetter
i'm sure they would have taken you
anyway i had to go to sleep away camp as
it was and it was humiliating
like i didn't want to go to sleep away
school but i always thought man i would
have loved
that one of the things i was curious
about is growing up in new hampshire
the way you did um did you
internalize politics to a higher degree
than you think most
americans because you wound up obviously
being like one of the most prominent
political voices among
comedians probably yeah because
we always worked on campaigns and you
know that because the
as you know all the politicians come
through
manchester um first and
uh you know back then i remember well
let's see like we worked on the
in seventh grade we worked on the uh
jesse jackson
and i remember i i had this seventh
grade teacher and i still hold this like
it was so uncool after that remember
jesse jackson called new york [ __ ] town
or whatever and like
it was like you remember this yes i do
and
my uh english teacher was like
well my family is working for the jesse
jackson campaign
but sarah your family probably doesn't
like him
and i'm just like actually we're working
on that campaign too
and if you thought he was anti-semitic
why would you be working on it
like it's just even in seventh grade i
was just like why would you point me out
like that i'm like the only jew i know
in this town i was listening to your
interview with burbiglia
and that was really fun to listen to and
it's just it
just being a comic it was just
interesting to hear like you know
anytime we're political on social media
or something people go like you
you you uh coastal elites or whatever
and it's like
i'm from new hampshire i you know i've
been in every state in this country
by car pretty much you know or like
train or
you know i mean i've been at more
southwest gates than
probably anyone except for maybe you or
like politicians
comedians i think have me beat in terms
of southwest gates
you know it's like you're famous but
you're not rich you know so it's like
um you're just sitting at the gate at
southwest and i remember one time
i was sobbing in um
santa maybe san antonio or santa fe
in this airport and i had just gotten
whatever happened i was just like by
myself sobbing i had like a
soaking wet tissue and i like people
came up and asked for pictures and i was
just like
you know like no no hug nothing
just like something for their facebook
page it was just it was just so
sad but it is funny it's like when
people say coast elites or all the stuff
and
i just go like i've been everywhere and
i'll tell you the first time i ever
heard of oat milk was when i was in
alabama
and the best vegan restaurants i've ever
been to is in kansas city
so i don't know what this like
you know uh i don't know it's very odd
you know
um me and mike owe you an apology sarah
because i think we were listing
comedians who we think could run for
office successfully and somehow
your name didn't come up even though
you're like the obvious one
no i'm not i have way too many well i
guess it's not skeletons in your closet
if your
closet's like open for people to see but
yeah i don't know i don't i don't know
that that's for me
but that's i did i was like oh what are
you saying
that was a good list chappelle would win
you know who wasn't mentioned and this
and chappelle is the one who said to me
during the last election he's like we've
got to get jon stewart to run
oh because he would win he would win and
he would be
great
[Music]
[Applause]
this episode of yang speaks is brought
to you by public goods the one-stop shop
for sustainable high-quality
everyday essentials made from clean
ingredients at an affordable price it's
everything from coffee to toilet paper
to shampoo to pet food public goods
is your new everything store rather than
buying from a bunch of single product
brands
public goods members can buy all of
their premium essentials essentially
in one place with a beautiful
streamlined aesthetic
and what they do is they search a globe
to find clean healthy eco-friendly
innovative products so i am right now
all about
the han soap it smells beautiful it's
like orangey cinnamony when you have a
good hand soap so that nice feeling and
you know it's coming from a good place
so i am a big fan we worked out an
exclusive deal just for yank speaks
podcast listeners you're gonna get 15
15 bucks off your first public goods
order with zero minimum no minimum
purchase at all so that's right
they're so confident and we are too
they're gonna love their products and
come back again and again that they're
giving you
both goods literally just giving you 15
bucks to spend on your first purchase
you have nothing to lose at all so go to
publicgoods.com
yang use the code yang at checkout so
that is
p u b l i c g o o d s dot com
forward slash yang get 15 off your first
order at public goods check it out
[Music]
so one reason i appreciate you there are
a number of reasons i appreciate you
sarah and admire you
but one is that you spent probably
the equivalent of years
spending spending time in different
communities around america trying to
unpack people's experiences and then you
responded
trying to unify through kindness and
understanding
which is really such the opposite of
like the customary approach
that that people seem to have
particularly in like the the kind of
cycles of social media and
the rest of it i just saw it as such an
uplifting quest on your part
and the fact that you could actually
do that in like a you know major
platform and
the way that you did i thought was very
very
singular like i thought to myself was
like is there anyone else who could
uh pull this off at this level and i
could not think of a soul
except for you yang
thank you i do yeah i mean it was
definitely i wanted to challenge myself
to say like i really want to
i try to do comedy that has
heart that is still hard comedy like
still
you know and um and
i also think we're we're all connected
and i i don't think we're as different
as we
feel because we're being separated by
misinformation i also feel like it
it isn't progress
like if i consider myself progressive
progress is to change
so like i'm wrong a lot and i love
changing i don't feel
i it's exciting to me you know when i go
oh nope i've got to say
you know like re remember the new words
the new pronouns the new whatever you
know like
i even see my boyfriend going like yeah
i met with this girl
woman today you know and it's those
little things
just seeing the that there's an
awareness in his head clicking off you
know from just what
is so ingrained in us is i find that
stuff exciting you know
but there is that thing online and it so
often comes from
the left of
just wanting to draw a line in the sand
and point to you as wrong and get to
point to mia's right
we get so excited to be right and point
to someone who's wrong and and i
i know i participated in as well but i
try to remember to
if do we want people to be changed or do
we just want to be able to point to them
as wrong in ourselves as right you know
like it's just like well remember
well four years ago this person said
this but
you know neil brennan has the best joke
about this
his analogy is like somebody going up to
lebron james and going
we have a picture of you when you're 14
and you're only five
two i'm like well but i grew
yeah but is this true is this your
picture are you five two
you know lebron was never five two
blasphemy
you took the harder approach i think
that that's part of why i
appreciated admired it so much you tried
to
build bridges of understanding people
who had
you know a different view or a different
political sense
uh and i think we really
needed that uh we still need it
you know like that there is still such
like a
divide uh and it is getting worse not
better for a variety of reasons
and i see you as one of like the few
people that tried to tackle it in a
meaningful
personal way that actually invested
you know years of your life in it um
it's something that
i feel like i can relate to because like
i undertook a similar mission
um in you know in a political realm
um and no to the extent that like
i made a contribution i'm really proud
um
but i feel like you've been doing the
same kind of work for years
and when i look at folks who are trying
to do it
like there aren't that many like it's
not like a
a huge legion uh of folks who
actually are um trying to understand
people who have completely differing
um politics or world views
yeah and it takes so little to connect i
mean you went from town to town and you
talk to people and you connect
i always say like um when friends go i i
can't even talk to this part of my
family
they're you know these trump cue
whatever crazy conspiracy
and i go do they watch walking dead you
know i don't know like it you know
there's always something and once you
connect
they're more open we're more rope well
we're all more open and we
were primed for change you know
but it to just be like i do notice on
the right like the thing that they're
most closed about is like
feeling judged you know
have you read uh jonathan heights work i
feel like you would love it uh if you
haven't
no um he wrote a book called the
righteous mind
that talks about the way that uh
conservatives and
liberals have uh different moral
palettes
uh and i i think you would love it where
he talks about how there are um
six universal values
let's see if i can get this right it's a
caring
fairness liberty
loyalty authority and sanctity
and progressives naturally skew towards
caring and fairness and conservatives
naturally skew towards loyalty authority
and sanctity
and then we construct liberty in
different ways either personally or or
societally but look at loyalty and
authority they're so connected to
fear oh yeah conservativism
corresponds to things like threat
sensitivity and disgust reflex
where like if you uh if you generally
are like you know
turned off by disgusting scenes or like
uh different types of uh even food
um you're more likely to be conservative
really
yeah and uh appetite for novelty
corresponds to liberalism
where if you just like new stuff you're
more likely
to be politically liberal i i read a
study that
when you're in a state of fear you no
matter who you are
you make more conservative choices and
that's why
you know um the right uses fear you know
the
caravans coming or whatever they need to
create to
make their followers malleable instead
of
be curious question things be interested
fight that human fear against the
unknown
you know and it is true that works on
liberals too where we give more
conservative responses after you scare
us
it's a you know it's a pretty universal
impulse we also apparently
get a bit more conservative as we age
yeah and we have to try to fight that
though
because you get set in your ways and set
in your ways means conservative
yeah it's um i mean you know i i looked
at myself it's like i
you know i feel like that hasn't really
happened to me as yet but uh who knows
man you know we're still young
i mean it happens to me in that like all
i want to do at night is like
watch a columbo and go to sleep yeah
i've become like old in that way but
when i hear like comics go oh we have to
learn all these new words or we can
i can't use this word or i have to be
sensitive to this topic
i can't say anything you know i go well
that's what old people are like you
don't even like you can't embrace new
that you can't think of new words you
can't think of something else to say
than
you know like i've used this a lot this
example a lot but i used to
defend saying gay or that's okay
because i go uh i'm from the boston area
it's i have gay friends it's not
you know what and then one day i just
heard myself and i was like
well you know what i'm the guy who goes
what i say colored i have colored
friends you know like
i'm him and you're like i don't want to
be that person
yeah surely i have other words i i i'm
like
my job is words i can think of other
things in two seconds and then
yeah it's so odd that instinct to want
to stay the same
[Music]
you know that credit card the one that
you're looking at and you're always
afraid like oh god don't tell me what my
credit card balance is like that and
you're voting your debt
upstart is something that can help you
pay that off get you better interest
rates and help you get out of credit
card debt and last year if you know
anything about 2020
you never know what life's gonna throw
at you you never know when you need
credit cards it's time to take control
with upstart so you know exactly
what to expect and if you have multiple
credit cards you can use upstart to
start
consolidating them and they make things
simple with one monthly payment
in one place so upstart is the fast
and easy way to get a personal loan to
pay off your debt
all online literally half a million
people have done this they use upstart
to get simple fixed
monthly payments and you can too so find
out how upstart can lower your monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com
yang that's upstart.com yang don't
forget to use our url and let them know
that yank speaks sent you
loan amounts can be determined based on
your credit income certain other
information provided in your loan
application
so go to upstart.com yang
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
jonathan hayt's research really
opened my mind in a different way um and
when i traveled the country like i had
an experience that
did verify a lot of what you just said
which is like if you actually
talk about the things that people want
for themselves their families
the things they enjoy like we we have
more in common than not
it's just that right now there are
massive
forces that actually unfortunately make
more money
putting us against each other that's
what it is
clicks yeah a lot of it's clicks
some of it's cable news and cable news
ratings yeah
if you have a 24-hour news channel
that's not news
they have to fill content and they need
to keep you to
you know uh through the commercial to
come on the other side it's that's
entertainment
you know i mean you know what i mean
like yeah obviously fox news but
you know msnbc anything that's 24 hours
is gonna be
is gonna have um bait
i remember the first time i was on one
of those cable news channels and it felt
like such an achievement i was in my 20s
but then when you get a bit older you
realize that they have a lot of
programming time to fill
maybe my three-minute segment wasn't
like the
important thing i thought it was it is
to the people who watch it but it is
true it's like
you know when you're making a show or
you're making doing an appearance
you know for a long time you think it's
the whole world we'll see or it's like
on everyone's minds like i would have
people
friends you know who are in show
business or whatever and they
there would be something online about
them and they'd be so distraught and
just think everyone's old i'm sure you
saw that blah blah
i would say let me do
you a favor nobody's googling you but
you
and certainly no one's uh
sorting it by date i mean like people
are just living their lives
well you certainly developed that sense
because you've been you know a public
figure for so long
i developed that sense pretty quickly on
the campaign where
uh it was fascinating sarah because
there was a long time when
there wasn't much upside in taking shots
at andrew yang because like i was just
like the scrappy underdog trying to get
like any kind of attention
and then you know when there was some
negativity it was an adjustment
but then i i actually wrote something on
my phone similar to what you just said
which is in my case my note was just
remember
that to everyone you're just the magical
asian man who wants to give everyone
money
yeah i mean yeah it's so sometimes
someone will reach out a friend or
something go like i don't know how
you i don't know how you deal with all
the negativity towards you
online and i go there is you know
because
like for survival i just don't look at
most of it you know and um
i just can't imagine like looking at
every single you know as a comedian you
there you have hecklers right in live
shows there's
there you know you get hecklers and
at first when i was young i would be so
hurt or
you know and um you realize
what the subtext of all these heckles
are which
is i exist right
you know and that's like times a
thousand on the internet you know
people just writing things to try to
prove they exist and and they're shocked
if you see it you know
that's true i i have poked my head in um
and someone has said something really
mean about me and that i've responded
and been like hey
sorry you felt that way like you know
like uh
like you know i'll like i'll keep at it
like smiley face or something like that
and then it completely defuses their
reaction they're just like oh
like uh you know never thought you would
saw this thank you for responding
it's like you just wanted to be seen or
heard it's very interesting because
you know i think
people just think they're shouting into
a void and they and and just like
energy's so catchy
you know so someone feels bad and they
want to make you feel
they want you we all feel this like that
knee-jerk reaction when you feel bad is
you want to make someone else feel that
maybe so you're not alone with it i
don't know what the reason is but
if you can change that energy to you
know which is what you did you respond
and you go oh
sorry you feel that way you know and
then that person felt
seen and it changed their energy to like
wow
thanks you know and um it's just
interesting and it's science you know i
know it sounds like a hair i'm out in
hell
la now and not new york and i'm like all
hippy dippy but it's science you know
energy it can't be what is it a
created nor destroyed but it can change
it can convert from negative
you know someone flips you off on the
street it's like
you you take it on and you it's catchy
you know
so if you can just really consciously i
mean what am i marianne williamson i
mean i love her i'm just kidding
but i i i sometimes i hear myself and i
go
aren't you a comic but it is true i'm
into science and it's real
you know i'm into the transformation of
energy too sarah
[Music]
this episode of yank speaks is brought
to you by liquid iv
the reality is this energy multiplier is
a game changer so i take this stuff
pretty frequently sometimes i take it
when i'm a little hungover and i'll see
you sometimes i take it just in the
morning give me a little pick me up it's
got a little caffeine in it but it's got
energy
it's got three times the amount of
hydration you get from a glass of water
it is a very quick and easy open the
packet dump in the water mix it up and
drink it
way to improve your energy in the
morning or frankly at any time
half americans right now say they
struggle with daily fatigue i bet that
number's higher
i am one of those this is an awesome way
to do it and plus
frankly the taste on this thing is
exceptional i have an apple pie one that
i love i love the lemon lime there's a
whole bunch you can get
you can grab your energy liquid iv in
bulk nationwide
at costco or you can get 25 off when you
go to liquid iv.com
use the code yang at checkout that's 25
off
anything you order when you use the
promo code yang yng
at liquid iv.com so start fueling your
adventures today get that fatigue
gone get the energy up liquid iv.com
promo code
yang
when i came up as a presidential
candidate
i went on cable news programs and
nothing would happen like there would be
no website traffic surge
there would be no boost in email signups
there would be certainly no donations
it would be like like like the cable
news appearance
was like like a pebble in the pond
and like nothing really would result um
but the opposite was true with podcasts
when i would sit down with someone and
have an hour-long conversation
then we would see noticeable surges in
email signups donations
like uh social media engagement
uh and so not being a total idiot i was
left with my team and i was like just
book me on any podcast
that has any kind of significant
audience because
this is actually working like people
will spend a bit of time with you
engage uh with what you're saying
and so i know you now have your own very
very successful
podcast that launched relatively
recently uh like how have you found
the experience thus far
it's ada it's kind of been like a
revelation for me because
you know everyone had podcasts and uh i
just felt like mom
everyone else is doing it and i've got
stand up and then suddenly one day i
didn't have stand up i mean
you know this is the longest i've gone
without doing stand-up
um since i was 18
you know and um it's really odd and i
had no place to like
put this and so i go all right now i'm
going to do a podcast and then
i uh
i it's just really um
i feel like it's it's it's uh um i'm re
i've really taken to the medium like i i
don't know
i don't know what the other side of it
is but for me i'm really enjoying it
i i digress like crazy it's i find it
interesting that the brain goes from
you know i learned see watch i'm digress
going to digress on top of digression on
top of a digression but
you know i learned early on in stand-up
that you don't need segways you know i
used to go
and speaking of mattresses i bought a
pillow and you know or whatever like
everything had to connect
in a in a verbally you know and then
i realized like in real life the brain
goes from one thought to the next to the
next
you know it's actually what made me
realize it was i was home with my mom
years ago
and my sisters and we were watching tv
and a commercial
a commercial for pumpkin pie
filling came on and it said it showed
like well the regular pumpkin pie
filling looks like this and it's like
the shape of the
can and mrs smith's pumpkin pie filling
like comes out like
all in a mess and everything like this
real pumpkin pie and my mother started
crying and we were like what's wrong and
she goes
i just the pumpkin pie filling look like
baby diarrhea and then i just thought
like you girls are all grown
and i'm not good and i just thought oh
my god the human brain
you know but it just showed me that
it's natural to go from one thought to
the next to the next
just pause just take a moment and let
your mind go to the next thing and
that's your segway you know
and with this podcast it's so loose
it's so messy and my i go from so many
thoughts you know like i'll i'll
i'll get a question um from a voicemail
and i'll start answering it and then
i'll go so far away from the topic that
i go what are we talking about oh yeah v
being vegan you know but i was like
talking about a thousand other things
and i like that that's okay and it's
very different than stand up for me
with stand-up my stand-up may feel
sometimes it is messy and loose and but
it's
ultimately i'm i'm a very slow honer
and i'm meticulous with my jokes even
though it doesn't
seem that way you know it's it's kind of
designed to feel very
off the cuff but over a few years i'll
like
really work on every little word and
stuff
and with this that's so immediate you
can't
and um i like that you know i'll listen
back sometimes and go oh i could have
said that so more
so much clearer so much more concise and
it's that's frustrating but
the fact that you have to just let it go
you know you you record it
you put it out and it's just and it's
extra scary in these times but i
it's i love it it makes me it's very
um liberating yeah
thank you it feels very liberating
you certainly deserve to be liberated um
in the sense that you've had this
incredibly fertile creative mind
and just letting it wander i feel like
would bring a lot of joy
to a lot of people who get to actually
interact with you in that way
yeah let me waste your time while you're
like doing the dishes
i get so much done when i'm listening to
podcasts and i like have listened to a
podcast it's nice
it is nice feeling like i can accompany
someone doing whatever it is they're
doing
uh i mean i love podcasting for similar
reasons
but i also love it because i get to
connect with again folks like you that
i've admired for a long time
uh well you know one thing that uh i
think hit a lot of people's radar was
when you endorsed bernie
um in 2016 and 2020 um i was a burner in
2016.
um i uh you know
it's like i still considered myself very
like bernie aligned
uh this past cycle um he and i got along
well on the trail i gotta say sarah one
of like the proudest
times on the trail for me was when
bernie
expressed affection for me it was like i
i felt like i've been
knighted he's so special
i love him so i love him so much but
yeah i mean there's
there's a lot of overlap in the venn
diagram of you and bernie
i think i always thought so i'll i'll
say
i mean i don't know how much people know
about this stuff but like i was
very very eager for him or really any of
the other candidates to
express support for universal basic like
uh
mayor's points of the trail uh and then
you know the timing worked out that
everyone
um embraced it uh really you know
essentially like after i drop down the
rest of it um because of
circumstances i mean if if one if the
pandemic proves anything it's
how much we it behooves us to have a
universal basic income
and and health care for everyone and
health care for everybody
and what that creates like you will who
you know they always say is like you say
who's gonna pay for it like bernie says
like everyone says who's gonna pay for
it when it's for social
programs but you know it's for like the
military or all these other things
nobody asks plus we're already paying
for it in ways big and small
i mean like there's there's so much
value that's getting chewed up by the
lack of health care
there's so much job lock uh there's so
much
excess expense that's going into the
system right now that's just not making
a lot of people stronger and healthier
so like the arguments against both
universal basic income and
uh universal healthcare really have gone
out the window with this pandemic
because like now everyone looks up and
is like
like okay when push came to shove it
turns out we could write 2.2 trillion
dollar like relief bill
like if we wanted to which we did yes
and it's it doesn't go out the window
you're giving people money
and that money is to spend and that
feeds
yeah if the government is responsible
for your
health and well-being they're also gonna
just
it will also behoove them to make sure
fresh healthy foods are accessible to
everyone
and not some elitist thing you know like
that's when i was asked about being
vegan it's like
i hate that i i always
it bothers me when when just living a
healthy life is something that is not
accessible to everyone
you know or like i said i went to pixar
before i did wreck-it ralph the movie
wrecker ralph they sent us to pixar and
it's like
it's the most beautiful place in the
world just rolling
hills of grass everyone's got a bike
just there for them a gym the the
work plan of the of the you know is like
open and and most conducive for learning
creativity and work
and all i could think was why isn't this
our schools why
why aren't there public schools like
this it just means
when you go to them if you go to a major
tech campus you get the same thing where
you're like what what is going on
there's so much you know what the word
is
sarah it's the word i was using on the
trail a lot the word is abundance
it's like such an atmosphere of
abundance
you know i and what you know there's no
reason why this shouldn't be
how can you pass by a public school in
half of this
country and they look like prisons you
know there's like bars on the walls it's
most of the country is operating in an
environment of scarcity
and then when you hit an environment of
abundance like pixar
or apple or google or any of these
places you're just like holy cow
like people here can eat healthily so
easily they can exercise so easily they
can
like get some kind of relaxation
resource so easily like
all the stuff that a lot of americans
feel like they don't have the money for
the time for etc etc
yeah so sarah you mentioned earlier uh
you made a joke about
um bedwetting as a kid
i know you had a major show
that was scheduled to be produced
but then kovit hit um aside from your
podcast i think that show is still in
the works do you have other
major projects that you're working on
yeah i had
two big ones coming up that are moved
exactly a year forward which you know
you go ugh but i'm so grateful because
in another year we'll be in such a
better place
and also it's always nice when you know
you have work in a year
you know like when you're in do it when
you're living like
gigs you know like i feel like i do odd
jobs it's so great knowing there's like
a couple solid things
coming up but yeah the musical right
is called the bedwetter and um it was
supposed to
start last may and uh um
rehearsals were starting in in march and
i flew to new york for
three months and um it immediately was
everything
was canceled and actually lost
um our partner it was myself and
josh harmon wrote the co-written
fountains of wayne
i was a fan of his not just from
fountains of wayne but from
um that movie he did uh music and lyrics
with drew barrymore
and hugh grant i thought that was so
well done yeah he's
we've been friends for a long time and
have been working on this for eight
years and then
you know so terrible yeah
what just yeah so that was crazy
he was born on halloween and he died on
april fool's day
seems apropos you know but
just so upsetting um but anyway that's
that's pushed
to 2022 and then a movie i'm doing is
pushed to 2022.
but um so there'll be a show is it it's
called the bedwetter and it's going to
yeah yeah it's at the um
the atlantic theater in new york
something for us all to look forward to
yeah it's about the year i'm 10. plus it
has
um incredible music from uh someone who
like this may be one of his last major
uh works or contributions yeah
yeah he had worked with um rachel bloom
on crazy ex
girlfriend yeah
well i'm super excited uh that we're
going to get to see so much of your work
coming up sarah
and uh your podcast is awesome you're
awesome
thank you for being such a voice for
humanity for someone who brings people
together
keep on transforming that energy we all
needed
likewise and um it's so fun talking to
you i feel like i know you
i've been a fan of yours for years so
this has been a real joy for me
yeah new hampshire buddies yeah you were
probably you were the cool kid dog was
like the
i was not the cool kid i was peripheral
i bet you were too i was like
got along with everyone i was peripheral
i i was like the brooding uh 90s
like kind of wannabe grunge skater did
you have many black
um rubber band bracelets i had something
like the equivalent
i had this like leather choker uh i
i wore a gray uh overcoat
um it was uh oh my god you were you're
lloyd dabbler
i was i was like lord dobler-esque i
would say i'll send you a pic
um i'll uh please
[Music]
you